la réhabilitation du centre ancien
commencé voilà dix ans porte ses fruits
il suffit de s'y promener pour pouvoir y
lire l'histoire nous l'avons fait avec
laurent mazuy experts du patrimoine et
coordonnateur de ce projet parmi les 800
façade rénovée le plus visible et le
plus atypique et sans doute cette
soixantaine de façade à pans de bois
issues de plusieurs époques
la première époque c'est le plusieurs
pans de bois très 194
on doit trouver à orléans avec ses
grandes croix de saint-andré ces croix
de saint-andré un peu plus loin on voit
bien qu'elles sont plus petites et elles
viennent faire un effet décoratif et
puis après le pont de bois gris avec ses
poutres verticale à la fin du xvième
siècle la réhabilitation du centre est
un travail de restitution
le parti pris est de donner à voir ce
qui a existé à une époque avant d'être
cachés comme ce fut le cas au 19e siècle
ce qu'il faut bien comprendre c'est que
l' architecture principalement l'
architecture à pans de bois
donc ce qu'on appelle le colombage va
être en fait entièrement recouvert à
partir de 1828 par obligations
municipales arrêté municipal tout
simplement pour la protection au feu au
même titre qu'on va interdire toutes les
saillies donc les ce qu'on appelle les
encorbellements les balcons tout ce qui
en fait rétrécit l'espace public et
facilite la communication des incendies
la technique du pan de bois a traversé
les époques car elle permet une
construction rapidement dans peu de mise
en oeuvre et elle permet aussi une
évolution du bâtiment
alors là on est face à une façade de 15
107 15 109 un pan de bois qui a pour
particularité d'avoir été restauré dans
son état d'origine avec une restitution
complète des sculptures et du parement
de brique lors ce qui est intéressant
avec ses façades à pans de bois par
rapport aux façades en pierre c'est que
les pannes otages donc les rythmes des
croix de saint-andré divise des
rectangles qui sont autant de logements
ou de possibilité de faire tenir des
fenêtres et donc en fait on peut comme
ça ouvrir avec d'immenses clervoy comme
on voit au sommet qui donne
naturellement une immense lumière
puisque la lumière venant du haut elle
pénètre très très profondément à
l'intérieur de la salle
on est sur un un pan de bois en cours de
restauration on va on le voit dans son
état brut
une fois qu'il a été décrété de son
enduit donc on peut voir tous les
fragments notamment les éléments de
couleurs on voit bien qu'il ya d'ici de
la couleur un pigment de sable jaune et
c'est ces informations que l'on vient de
collecter et qui après naturellement
sont mis dans la restauration si
toutefois il resterait dans l'état du
xviiie
car ce jaune est une couleur du 18e
alors la coloration en fait des pans de
bois commence au milieu du xvième siècle
d'après nos informations la chose peut
évoluer naturellement en fonction des
trouvailles qu'on peut faire c'est tout
d'abord du rouge
ça sert à protéger le bois ça n'est pas
n'a pas de fonction esthétique bien que
les jours d'hitler les remplissages 1
peuvent être souvent à l'époque en
briques en de près de la sologne et là
on voit bien un rapport rouja rouge
voilà maintenant rien n'est avéré sur la
volonté de faire une grande façade rouge
au xviiie siècle
l'esthétique des villes reconsidérer à
orléans une vaste campagne de ravalement
met en scène les façades et notamment
les pans de bois qui se colorent
affirmant leur dimension graphique
deux siècles plus tard étonnamment la
démarche est similaire
tout ça crée naturellement par le rythme
des façades un aspect paysager ou plein
de matériaux de couleurs reviennent
comme ça à l'espace participent comme ça
aux perspectives dans un ensemble qui
n'est pas aussi sans intégrer des
éléments de modernité quand on change
les menuiseries on met les doubles
vitrages enfin plein d'éléments comme ça
où on est à la fois pas le dos à la
modernité
mais c'est un mélange un point d
équilibre subtil entre les deux pour le
pour le plaisir de tous des rêveurs et
des promeneurs
et